good morning believe nation today's
message is stick to simple ideas over to
you Steve Wynn TV go my dad taught me
that what you want to do is stick to
simple ideas and I don't know why Tony I
don't know where or when but ever since
I was a kid the idea building something
that would make people go wow has struck
me it's just about the coolest thing in
the world to do now it's not saving
lives in the real sense or doing
something really noteworthy but it has
kept me a happy happy person and I was
little bit though well I think I got to
build another hotel because maybe next
time just maybe I could get it right
along the way we've created 150 or 250
thousand jobs and I think the most
satisfaction I've ever gotten has been
the fact that the family the employees
the staffs of the hotels here and abroad
and their family have all sorta merged
into one yes and we've got this this
very familial kind of organization which
is very satisfied with live in the
hotels yes you know there every day with
my family in its great life I love this
message because entrepreneurs we tend to
overcomplicate things we make things
more complicated than they need to be
and often the biggest idea is the ones
that take off the ones that have
momentum the ones that change the world
are the simple ones I remember my first
software company we had a great product
we really believed in it but we had a
hard time explaining what we did we had
a hard time at the elevator pitch stage
and we felt like mean if we can just get
somebody when we're looking for
investors there's somebody to sit with
us on a couch and if we had half an hour
at their time we could explain it to
them and they would get it and we fully
believe that they would understand you I
want to invest in us but nobody would
give us the half an hour nobody gives
you the half an hour because it's too
complicated this business I have now of
helping entrepreneurs
it started to take off in a big way when
I embrace belief because it was a simple
idea it was easy to understand it was
easy to explain it was easy to embrace
and then people wanted to consume it and
share it I remember the first newsletter
that I put out that was talking about
believe was my best newsletter ever an
engagement went up fifty percent on my
youtube channel the first believed by
video that I put up that video had a
hundred thousand views in one month
where my second best video took a year
to get to a hundred thousand views
simple is better I'm currently coaching
a young entrepreneur and encouraged him
to get him down to one word just like i
did with believe just like hopefully you
guys are doing with your company and he
couldn't he's down to three words and so
one of the things that I then challenged
him to do was come up with who's your
enemy right if you want to build a
movement you have to have an enemy a
nemesis who is it or what is it as a
concept or person and he couldn't come
up with one you get to come up with
three he's over complicating things
right stop over complicating your
business stop over complicating what you
staying for making easy for people to
understand what you do and spread the
message for you belief so my question
today for you guys today is do you over
complicate things or you keep things
simple I'm curious to find out leave it
in the comments below thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events presa this British TV go